ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد بالتزامني مع
حاله الهدوء الزلزاليه الذي هي او التي
تشهدها مناطق تركيا وسوريا حاليا تصاعدت
حده الشائعات والمخاوف من زلزال مدمر قد
يصيب المنطقه العربيه التكهنات والتخمينات
بحدوث هذا الزلزال ظهرت بوضوح عبر وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي حيث تم افتراض حدوثه في
الاسبوع الاول من مارس الحالي وكانت مصر
احدى الدول التي خمنها ووسط تلك المخاوف
الشعبيه كشف رئيس معهد البحوث الفلكيه في
مصر جاد القاضي ان بلاده امنه من الزلازل
المدمره ولا يمكن ان تتعرض مدنها الساحليه
لموجه تسونامي كذلك اضاف ان الكود الزلزلي
في مصر يتم تحديثه بشكل مستمر مشيرا الى
انه يتم يوميا رصده ومتابعه النشاط
الزلزالي للجمهوريه وكان العالم الهولندي
او العالم الذي توقع حدوث هزه بمصر ولبنان
قد اكد ان تلك المنطقه عرضه للنشاط
الزلزالي ولكنه نبه الى انه لا يمكن
التنبؤ بتاريخ حدوث هذه الهزه
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من القاهره
دكتور عباس شراقي استاذ الجيولوجيا في
جامعه القاهره ومن عمان غسان سويدان رئيس
مركز رصد الزلازل الاردني اهلا بكم ضيوفي
اسمحوا لي ان ابدا من القاهره طالما
تحدثنا منذ قليل عن الاخبار التي تخص مصر
في الواقع كانت هناك تكهنات بان يضرب او
تضرب هذا ارضيه مصر في الاسبوع الاول من
مارس وحدث ذلك
هزه وليس زلزال الحمد لله على كل شيء ولكن
سؤال اللي يبقى مطروح استاذ دكتور عباس
الى اي مدى هناك امكانيه دقيقه للتنبؤ
بالزلازل ومتابعه تحركات الطبقات الارضيه
تحياتي لحضرتك واللي ضيفك الكريم وكل
الساده المشاهدين
بدايه
الزلازل ممكن تحدث على اي بقعه على سطح
الارض هذا من البدايه ولكن نعلم ان هناك
اماكن فرصه حدوث الزلازل فيها اكبر من
غيرها وعندما تحدث الزلازل الشده في هذه
الاماكن او القوه الزلازل ايضا تكون قويه
في اماكن واقل في اماكن اخرى هذا يعني
معروف جيولوجيا
لكل المتخصصين ايضا لا يمكن من الناحيه
العلميه التنبؤ باي زلزال ولكن هناك بعض
الشواهد عندما يحدث في بعض الاماكن اللي
فيها نقول عليها احزمه زلازل فالمتوقع ان
يحصل زلازل اليوم وغدا وبعد غد في مناطق
المحيط الهادي او على راسها اليابان
ونشوف بعدها باكستان وفيه يعني عندنا
اندونيسيا واستراليا والجزر المحيط الهادي
وفي شيلي وبيروق كل هديه اماكن اماكن
زلازل والزلازل يوميه ولكن احنا المفروض
يعني العامه دلوقتي ياخدوا من هناك درس
تعلمناه في الاسابيع الماضيه شفنا البعض
اولا المتنبئ من هولندا وليس بعالم ولا
متخصص وليس معه درجه علميه حتى يعني نتحدث
معه ولكن هو يعني له فيديوهات على
اليوتيوب دكتور هو هو ليس ليس قدمناه
كعالم فقط للتوضيح ولتحديث هذه المعلومه
ويروج لها على انه عالم وباحث في علم
الزلازل
ايوه هو للاسف هو ليس بعالم لان احنا في
البدايه يعني اخذنا كلمه عالم ولم نبحث
فيها لان المفروض ان احنا عندنا ثقه وان
ما فيش واحد هيقول على نفسه عالم او
الوسائل الاعلام هتنقل على شخص عادي ان هو
عالم هو ليس بعالم وايضا كباحث هو لا يتبع
جهه بحثيه علشان نشوف هذه الجهه متخصصه او
لا وهو يعني عنده موقع الكتروني وهو
الوحيد اللي في هذا الموقع وبيبث فيديوهات
وبيستخدم هندسه النجوم وربطها بالزلازل
وهذا ليس علم حتى هذه اللحظه ليس علم من
الطرف هذه الفكره يعني حضرتك دكتور فقط
لانقل النقطه
ولنتقاسم النقاط لانك اتيت على نقاط جد
مهمه ومتعدده حتى يناقشنا كذلك بخصوصها
الاستاذ غسان حضرتك ترى دكتور يعني ملخص
الحديث بانه من الصعوبه مما كان التنبؤ
بالزلازل استاذ غسان حضرتك كيف ترى
الموضوع هل يمكن دراسه
تحركات الصفائح بشكل يمكننا من التنبؤ ولو
بطريقه تقريبيه
مساء الخير الك ستي وللاستاذ الدكتور عباس
طبعا انا لن اضيف على ما قال الدكتور عباس
بخصوص العالم الهولندي هو قال واوجز وانا
اتفق معه تماما بكل ما قال وبالنسبه
للدكتور الهولندي
بالنسبه الى حركه الصفائح نعم نحن نعلم
طريقه حركه الصفائح واتجاهاتها ونراقبها
وبعد كل زلزال انت بتعرفي لما يكون في
زلزال كبير فهو هذا الزلزال قادر على
زياده سرعه حركه الصفيحه فهناك اجهزه
مثبته نسميها اجهزه الرصد
موقعي وهي اجهزه بالليزر وهي دقيقه جدا
تقيس بالمليمتر ونعرف كم سرعه واتجاه
الصفيحه هذه ومن بعد الزلزال من مواقع
المحطات الزلزاليه نعرف نوعيه الحركه على
هذا الفالق ولكن
التنبؤ تعني انني سوف اعلم مكان ووقت وقوه
الزلزال وهذا علم ليس صحيح نعم هناك ناس
يبحثوا فيه ويحاولوا ان يجدوا بعض الشواهد
او بعض الثوابت ويربطوها في بعض في
الكواكب في النجوم بالامطار بالرياح ولكن
طبيعه الزلازل وكيفيه حصولها والميكانيكيه
التي تحصل فيها الزلازل يصعب علينا معرفه
متى سوف يحصل زلزال وكما تفضل الدكتور
عباس يعني نحن نتوقع نتوقع ان نعلم من
خلال الرصد الزلزالي اصبحت لدينا علم
بمواقع حدوث الزلازل او ما يسمى البؤر
الزلزاليه او
الاحزمه زلزاليه الناريه يعني عنا في
الوطن العربي خلينا نقول على فائق البحر
الميت اللي بيمر في الاردن وفي سوريا والى
جنوب تركيا
نحن نعلم انه منطقه خليج العقبه فيها نشاط
زلزالي وه معتدل يعني من نسجل وبشكل يومي
وبشكل دوري ولكن هذه الزلازل تعتبر حركه
طبيعيه الى سطح الارض الى سطح الكره
الارضيه ولكن موضوع اني انا اقول لك في
وقت فلاني او اي انسان او عالم صعب
ولم تثبت حتى الان طيب دكتور عباس ان كان
ليس بامكان العالم ان يحدد نقطه
الزلزال وتاريخه هل يمكن الحديث عن منطقه
اليوم هناك الكثير من الاخبار في الواقع
فتحت جدلا كبير
شائعات يروج لها البعض بان هناك زلزال قد
يضرب المنطقه العربيه حضرتك كيف تتابع هذه
المعلومه ما مدى دقتها ما مدى امكانيه
حدوثها
يعني انا عايز يعني اوضح احنا شفنا
الاسابيع الماضيه التوقعات او التنبؤات
سواء من
المتنبئ الهولندي او من احد
المتخصصين في العراق اللي ربط ما بين حركه
الكواكب والامر
وحدوس زلازل وذكر ان هناك زلزال يوم 8
يعني ده في الغالب على اساس ان القوى
الجذب للكواكب والامر هتكون اقوى بالنسبه
للكره الارضيه احنا الاول زي ما حضرتك
ذكرت في البدايه الاسبوع الاول من هذا
الشهر اللي هو كان يعني بيحذروا منه كان
هو الاهدى على الاطلاق حتى النهارده اليوم
ما فيش ولا زلزال في تركيا شدته فوق
الاربعه يعني الزلازل اللي حصلت كلها يعني
اقل من اربعه ريختار وهذا يعني لم يحدث من
قبل منذ 6 فبراير وايضا على مستوى العالم
ما فيش زلزال اليوم شدته اعلى من سته
يوميا كان في بيبقى فيه سته فاذا توقعاتهم
خابت تماما يعني كانوا بيقولوا ان الاسبوع
الاول من مارس وبالتحديد يوم 8 ده هتحدث
فيه زلازل فوق السبعه وربما تصل الى
تمانيه
واحنا بنقول ده يعني يعني يثير الذعر
لهذه المناطق خاصه
للسكان اللي هم في تركيا وفي سوريا اللي
هم شافوا الامرين في الزلازل الاخيره لما
نحن كمان يعني نرهبهم اكتر ونقول لهم اللي
جاي اشد وهذا غير صحيح فبالتالي لما ننقل
نفس التوقعات ونقول ان في في الاردن او ان
في في مصر هيبقى زلزال قوي على اي اساس تم
هذا يعني ممكن يحصل زلزال فعلا ممكن ولكن
فرصه حدوثه قليله للغايه كما ذكر
البحر الميت صحيح ولكن هذا اللي حابين
نفهمه بطريقه مبسطه
لمشاهدنا لماذا امكانيه زلازل في منطقتنا
العربيه رغم اننا نتحدث عن صفائح
الاناضوليه العربيه الافريقيه واسعه عن
المنطقه العربيه لماذا نحن شبه
بعيدون ان صح التعبير عن امكانيه ان يكون
هناك زلزال قوي رغم ان تركيا سوريا شهدت
زلزال قوي الاقوى منذ قرن الاماكن
الاماكن القريبه من تركيا وهنا نقول سوريا
هي الاقرب للزلازل الخطره يقل هذا الخطر
كلما نتجه جنوبا لان الفوالق الموجوده في
تركيا ليست موجوده في المنطقه العربيه
لدينا البحر الاحمر وهذا ليس فالق النشط
بالنشاط الموجود في تركيا او في المحيط
الهادي ايضا المناطق الاخرى العربيه اللي
قريبه من زي سوريا يمكن عندنا منطقه
الخليج العربي واتصالها بايران ايران
شمالا وجنوبا هي معرضه لبعض الزلازل ولكن
ليس بالخطوره اللي موجوده في تركيا اذا لو
بنرتب الدول العربيه في مخاطر الزلازل
هنقول سوريا تاتي في المقدمه ثم هنا هنا
يعني الدول المجاوره لايران والبحر الاحمر
وخليج العقبه وخليج السويس هذه اماكن يعني
فيها هزلات ولكن متوسطه بلا زلازل ضعيفه
وشكرا على الاجازه اختم معك يا استاذ غسان
هناك دائما حديث عن عنصر المفاجاه هل هذا
العنصر حاظر وبقوه فيما يخص علم الزلازل
السلام عليكم